are you a football fan huge yeah yeah
you are and your team is the dolphin
dolphins Florida you stick the Dolphins
yes I well that's all we had when I was
a kid we didn't have it was one team
were you a a Dan Marino fan huge I met
him not nice to me but he wasn't nice to
no not to me but it's okay it's okay I
don't hold a grudge he was really nice
to me was he really so
I he's like I have his phone number
we're like best friends real damn it no
the truth is Steve lavini who's in in
the other room he's been both our agents
for mine for like 30 years and and you
always used to book me at the Sunrise
remember New Year theater Sunrise which
is now it's some sort of church now it's
not even a it's not even a I pray there
many nights as well it should be a
church but Dan Marino used to come to
the shows and a couple of times he would
throw me a pass from the audience I
actually caught passes he treated me
nice talk about your experience with Dan
Marino it wasn't
so like bestie like bestie so how'd it
go with you not good I was it it wasn't
I don't know it wasn't a great it wasn't
a horrible thing it was just I was I
went and it's also for charity so I
went seriously it was make a wish I made
a wish that didn't come true no I'm I'm
serious it was it was for Jim Kelly's
son's foundation so I go and everyone is
there I'm John mackenro to every sport
every big and I was talking to you know
John Macker my mom had a tennis shop
when I was a kid couldn't have been
nicer everyone was nice but the only
reason I was there cuz came through Jim
Kelly's people I said I really want to
meet Dan Marino and he said I'll make it
happen so Jim said did you meet Dan yet
and I said no I'll make it happen so
yells across there's like this bar it
was at the Hard Rock or something he
said Dan you know come say hi to katop
and it it just went South from there he
just said like who and what and then he
came around it never came around I went
around to go say hi to him and uh and he
said uh you
okay why I don't know I just remember
like it was just an hour ago and I said
I'm sorry what's that he said are you
okay and I said yeah I'm fine how are
you he was your nose bleeding I don't no
I don't exactly so I just like you know
yes I'm fine and then and then he just
you know went on his way and I said well
that was I guess that was me getting to
meet him so I thought that was weird so
I said to my friend let's let's let's go
so we went around around this back door
to get out the back and as we went out
the back they said you can't go this way
can that's when John macro came in the I
said I talk to him and I said now how
see how easy it is like how nice John
mackenro was to me he didn't have to be
right and then I said hi to a couple of
the people and I went to go back the
other way and as I went around back
again Dan marito comes in and I said are
you okay and he said what's that I said
are you okay he said yeah why I said
okay so making sure okay it was just it
was just the most weirdest night and
never said hi never just weird Oh it
sounded like he was just checking on you
you're just checking on cheing on me Mak
sure that's not bad not a mean terrible
I thought it was going to be worse
that's why I said it wasn't that bad
just bad you're okay it was just I'm and
thank God I'm okay you just had high
expectations well not well a hello is
not really that high expect but it was
more than supposed to go there just to
meet him but he was worried about you
yeah it's more than it wasn't just a hey
and then walk away I do get you get that
a lot when people say you okay
[Music]
and